the media today I'm more and more
content providers we're providing
content just by this very interview and
and you need a lot of it
and to get people to read what you have
to say or hear what you have to say or
to see what you think as you express
yourself in broadcast me in the
broadcast medium
you have to tend to you know create
crises or scandals or gotcha moments and
I I think it's an unfelt I frankly think
it's an unfortunate development in the
media today that you know I was
reflecting on a new story I was reading
during the course of today and it was
you know it wasn't it expresses opinion
about why it was X expresses outrage
about why so you have this desire to
turn things into scandals and crises and
to elevate interest to cut through to
grab attention when you're a producer of
media content and you know in certain
many ways I see the courage of that
particular issue issue in that light I'm
not going to talk about the merits of it
or anything like that but you know so
often now we we have these these these
crises of these issues and it's not to
devalue them in any way but you tend to
get a period when there's sort of like a
mob mentality around the media focusing
on something so one minute it might be
what Dominic Cummings has done the next
understandably you know something like
black lives matters then it's before we
had weave we had the Arab Spring we
we've had from when you know apparently
the whole Middle East was going to
change and for months the media were
focusing on what's going on in the
Middle East and this was in that rising
of democracy and things have gone pretty
much back to the way they were so I
think in the me to movement and all of
these things I just think there's a
tendency to gray
issues and elevate the intensity of
debate around them in a way that
actually alienates many many voters and
and so you know you know I don't have
said I'm not going to comment on the
particular issue I just think it in
terms of whether anyone rightly or
wrongly or anything else but but all
what the impact might be but I just
think that we've got to be careful not
to believe that just because the media
get excited about something for a
sustained period that actually data
issue is of itself necessarily relevant
to the public it's just something that
I'm not saying it wasn't but but I'm
quite skeptical about the way everybody
jumps onto an issue and it blows up for
a period and then it almost goes as
quickly as it came that's very
interesting Linton do you think that
you're clearly you the crisis has been
and will remain big news across the
world sort of very news heavy lots of
people locked down probably consuming
more news and never before because the
uncertainty do you think that the
relationship between sort of the the
public and the media is changing as well
as pasilla perception broadly speaking
of the media is changing is that going
to have a this quite have an impact it's
really interesting so early on in you
know in their tracking polling and so
yeah I mean it was speaking about polls
before but in terms of trying to
understand things rather than you know
just say what they say what has been
interesting is people the the two groups
the two issue of whether people turned
to the government for information and
interestingly to television for
information so television consumption
was up then what we saw was some and and
trusting government was up because
people were looking for a solid reliable
source and this wasn't you know partisan
debate this is a big problem facing my
country facing me facing the world
how should I think about it what's going
on this is someone managing this too you
know is there a plan and so people were
very desperate for news and for
information they weren't looking for
commentary they were wanting to apply
their own filter their own prism over
the issue but they did return to
television and to a lesser extent but
also increased use of digital media but
at the same time we sort of start to see
the deterioration in trust in the media
and that was because there was this
feeling that actually I want to hear
what's going on but I don't need a
journalist to interpret it for me I
don't need a commentator express their
opinion I just want to hear the fact and
I want to evaluate those facts or what
I'm being told and I'll make the
judgement about it so there wasn't
increasing interest in hearing from
government and an increase in trust
there was an increasing interest in
hearing particularly from television
broadcast broadcasters because people at
home - and they were wanting to get the
news and get the information and hear
from their leaders via that medium but
they didn't want the commentary